paris 10 907 le dessin animé allait
naître émile cole dans son atelier
montmartrois créé attrait lumière et
méliès le premier santos les profanes se
rend-il compte du travail gigantesque
que nécessite un dessin animé
il faut 24 dessin pour une seconde de
projection autrement dit 1440 images
pour 60 secondes où près de 15000
composition pour diminuer les images
sont filmés une à une
et voici le résultat de cette patiente
et l'inspiration aux ateliers risacher
angers ville dessous mais les principaux
dessin de son prochain film
l'animateur se met au travail une fois
les calques termini les dessins sont
transposés et colorié sur cellulo aux
productions du cygne l'humoriste du bout
c'est fait la tête de son personnage
anatole tandis qu'un de ses amis lui
sert de modèle pour ménès
paul grimont dans la verve poétique nous
a déjà souvent ravis termine un nouveau
film dont voici le décor l'école
française du dessin animé création de
chez nous affirme sa vitalité
déjà des réalisations intéressantes dû à
de jeunes talents ou à des vétérans
comme andré rigal ont vu le jour un
proche avenir confirmera ce nouvel
espoir du cinéma français